[Music]
we've actually talked about this before
but uh a new update came up so i just
thought it'd be funny back it's like the
most you remember that giant uh
hippo problem because of pablo escobar
wait there was a hippo problem can you
update me because i'm not caught up so
colombia
uh you know back in the 1980s uh pablo
escobar had his own private zoo because
you know he's obviously a g like that
drug dealers are just big kids man and
he brought literally just a handful of
hippos over into his private zoo and
hippos are not you know uh regularly in
colombia and they uh grew to a
population of about 80.
since then yeah so
that's prompting biologists to express
concern over the environmental impact
and threat to human safety because
hippos are pretty [__] dangerous and
obviously introducing a giant animal
like that into the ecosystem have you
seen them eat a watermelon
yeah you could throw a whole watermelon
in its mouth it just goes bam they're
pretty aggressive they don't have teeth
they have like tusks
they smash a watermelon like it's a
puffed [__] popcorn you ever seen a
video of that hippo following that boat
and like trying to like eat the [__]
boat no he ate a boat trying to and it's
like chasing them the whole time because
i guess they're pretty aggressive like
don't come out and chase human beings
apparently why does this guy be so
they're lost are they the second most
either aggressive or second most attacks
on humans i think the second list of
animals what's the first
i don't think panda no dude you see the
video of the guy jumping into a panda uh
i think somewhere in asia he jumps into
a panda uh cage or whatever the [__] and
the panda starts wrestling with him dude
did he [__] him up yeah is the hippo the
one like the
like a small like did they have minimal
teeth and they have small ears yeah yeah
yeah yeah they got a big ass mouth dude
what do you think the panda did that
made this guys go i'm [__] i'm gonna
[__] you up he was like trying to like
[__] with it and then panda got up and
started wrestling it and double leg
taken like it kept taking it down i like
to think he's just at the zoo and then
this pain is looking at him wrong he's
like what the [__] are you looking at
what are you looking at [__] hey
look at the [__] out of here got jack
black's voice wait what happened to
these they they grew to 80 so is that
bad yeah so so again there's just
environmental impacts from 80 giant
hippos you know in a region that doesn't
have it uh native to it so um
what were they they found it they found
a solution though they just dropped 80
[__] hippos into the wild yeah no no
they only dropped a handful pablo
brought originally and then they all
started [__] each other they dropped
their invasive did can i can i guess yes
they dropped a [__] ton of marbles down
and then the hippos started eating them
up that's hungry hippos and they died
and then hopefully they died
were those marbles or were those just
like little white balls ah they're just
like plastic balls yeah dude hippos yeah
and you [__] slam it try to beat your
friends so with this uh invasive hippo
problem uh their
solution anybody guess
put them on a boat and bring them back
well if it's the texan way you get in a
helicopter and you put a machine gun on
and just mow them down yeah just like
that that's not the way targeted
airstrike no no transportation there's
slightly
less murderous slightly less murderous
they just put up in a different country
they tried first
to neuter the beasts right oh come on so
they neutered it and gave it they tried
so but traditional surgical
sterilization is too dangerous and
demanding to scale up only 11 of the
hippos have so far been sterilized that
way according to the local authorities
so on this past friday however the
regional environmental agency announced
its efforts to control the population
that has led to 24 more hippos being
treated with the new method darts laden
with the contraceptive drug gonokan
they're shooting their dicks with
they're like blow darting their dicks
they're blow darting them with birth
control whoa so they can't move from
afar you gotta have good hand that run
out
so because it's not permanent right you
gotta re-up well the hardest part about
that is that they have to it's not just
like one dart is gonna give you birth
control they usually they're supposed to
receive multiple dosages so even being
able to like track the hippos that they
shot prior to give them their like
second dose of pfizer they need to
[__] hit them with gps first like a
gps dart oh yeah
yeah
so they know where all of them are
because don't they do that to endangered
species like they tag them and [__]
right well these [__] ain't
even dangerous they're they're trying to
get them out you know man what how big
is the target a hippo a hippo's
situation they're invasives is it big
they just hit both sides it's like yeah
pretty big maybe bigger than a cow
smaller than an elephant
has anybody ever did a blow dart gun
before is that i don't think it's
actually blowed out i think the actual
gun that has darts in them just looks
funnier in like cartoon theory i like
blow darts
if you inhale like this you drink the
[__] they gotta do it like like how
birth control is today like they gotta
do like once a day
so experts are suggesting to give them
three doses based on studies comparisons
made with other large animals such as
horses and the same drug has been tested
on other wild animal populations
including wild horses in the united
states kangaroos in australia and wild
cattle in hong kong
but pretty much the way that they're
tracking the efficacy of it is by
measuring hormone levels in hippo feces
why don't they just
kill them
dude they doing too much work bro
they're an invasive species they it's
weird you think about the people who
track the hippo population dude they
[__] are in love with them
won't you bury them you [__] losers
you know what i mean like yeah
these hippos are out here destroying
villages and biting [__] amazonian
kids and [__]
that's in the story too yeah in colombia
they doing all this that's in the
article
they're destroying all these drug labs
and stuff
[Laughter]
these hippos are vigilantes [__] man
behind the dip this cocaine they [__] it
up did i miss drug dealers who did like
hardcore sick [__] like that man pablo
escobar setting up a zoo
did he know he was gonna breed a whole
like family of them you know it's funny
he he only started his collection with
one male and three females
oh that's so like this lucky man there's
nothing one male that's been doing his
that's kind of tight i love that it's
all escobar's hippos too like there's
there's the lineage of escobar
it really is escobar's hippo that's good
ratio like the funny thing is i guess
it's not funny but it says upon his
death other species of exotic animals
were relocated but the hippos were left
because they were too difficult to
capture and transport hell yeah so they
just left them they're like ah you're
too fat and it says they soon began
multiplying spreading around the
magdalena river basin from their
original home some hundred miles east of
the city of medellin damn wait why don't
they just leave them oh because the the
and they say
research has shown negative effects of
hippo waste on oxygen levels in bodies
of water which can affect fish and
ultimately humans hippos also pose a
threat and the ecosystem agriculture
into the security of people in affected
areas
a hippa yeah
where do they belong and in may 2020 a
hippo attack left a 45 year old man
seriously injured hippos come from
africa is that where they come from yeah
all hippos yeah so they so pop pablo
went all the way there to bring him out
yeah or or cultures he's like i gotta
pause this uh process for a little bit i
gotta take a boat trip real quick
poachers poachers sell them like you
could get tigers you get all these wild
animals because they'll trap them out
there and then they'll sell them they
usually get them as a baby
yeah they usually get them as a baby the
common hippo also known as the large
hippo found in east africa and then the
pygmy hippopotamus is mainly in west
africa it's more shy and solitary look
at that [__] hippo got the hippo guy
right here we got a hippo guy i i'm
really into uh animal poaching and
studying and studying
not partaking
but you know how it's [__] up
they'll
they'll grab like the the pride or the
or the or the or the pack right and
it'll just kill the adults off because
you can't have them like in a zoo and
[__] and they just take the cubs
and then they have they raise them
captive
the google of hippos yup this guy knows
hippos dude hippo hippo facts bro and
it's hard to ship a big [__] hippo
you got to ship smaller ones so you get
them juvenile you know what i saw that
was [__] up with the the potion what
was that one uh animal that has like
pretty much like nails all over their
body
porcupine no it's not a porcupine it's
got like a hedgehog whatever this nail
thing is
pangolin what the hell [__] was the
penguin it looks kind of like an
armadillo it's what they thought kovid
was spread by
penguin yeah yeah it was like that was
one of the theories it was like
early march april theories yeah
likes to eat rare that's a penguin yeah
that's true i've never seen that
look at that [__] i think it's right but
the thing is people are poaching them to
take off those like uh their scales but
they're literally the same material that
are made uh our nails are made of so
what do they use them for
chinese hot yeah it's like chinese
people were taking it turning into some
sort of like tea or some sort of like a
remedy
it's so sad dude if i ever saw that i
would think that i discovered it yeah
for sure that's that's not a normal
looking answer and the crazy penguins
because of like their type of armor
right when they get us
attacked or scared they kind of like a
roly-poly they just kind of like uh
freeze and they ball up but obviously
for human poaching that's easier because
now they don't move they just get picked
up and they just is that the thing from
raya anybody else see disney's right or
am i the only one it's similar but the
thing in raya is i think a mythical
creature that's the size of like you
know a hippo oh okay same thing though
that's like the worst super power yeah
the [__] roly-poly
it's not good yeah i mean it works for
like the regular effects on that species
like endangered stuff you know like if
humans would just use it as a [__]
soccer ball hmm yeah that might hurt
your foot though if you try to kick the
[__] out that looks so dope you ever
seen one in real life hell no okay
you know why the dodo bird got extinct
because um
they never had a predator so they
evolved without fear so when humans and
and and their livestock came to the
island just like that's a big [__]
bird and i'm hungry and the birds will
come up to them you can just grab them
[__]
cut them up eat them
and it's friends of him i'll run from
you what are they doing
dodo bird yup massive lots of protein
yup they said like the humans isn't what
killed them off it was their livestock
that came in like they had like dogs and
whatever and they just [__] they just
[__] ravished that little island
i bet you never thought you're gonna get
dodo facts in this video huh stupid [__]
i don't even know what a dodo bird looks
like it's big as [__] dude coming at you